I know that probably thinking this
Christmas Christmas music is helping
that's not more handsome so everybody I
made it my surgery is being completed
that's what Pleasant
and
and I feel awful I'm feeling a little
bit like the goat in the bottle Diaries
I have a meeting today don't everybody
is charlie Tom Holland just being loopy
as hell hocked up on whatever drugs they
gave him after he got his wisdom teeth
out so as you can see there isn't a lot
of noise happening about the spider-man
far from home trailer there are actually
two separate trailers that Sony cut
before CC XP so they've actually been
sitting on two separate trailers this
whole time so I'll explain what's going
on with that and there was a really
funny Marvel interview that was done
where they talked a little bit about the
problems they're having between
spider-man and Avengers endgame in
spider-man far from home in how it's
just kind of messing up their Avengers
endgame plans
we're still doing that IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Tom Holland moment on the video any
funny moment at all I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so just last
week they showed off the CC XP Brazil
Comic Con trailer then Tom Holland
explained why that one didn't make it
online just for you guys exclusively
because sometimes we just want to show
our support and you guys have been so
amazing to us ever since I got this job
and I guess we just wanted to come in
and say thank you really and that was
our way for a Marvel and Sony to say
thank you and I hope you enjoyed it we
loved it it's amazing to see something
you've worked so hard on become a
reality and then share it with the
people who really want to see it so
again thank you for having us see cxp
it's been amazing now this is him
speaking for Sony not Marvel that's
marketing far from home so this is all
Sony cutting all the trailers dealing
with all the footage that you're going
to be seeing between now and July what
happened is is that as CC XP they were
going to post that trailer online but
because that happens so close to the
Avengers end game trailer dropping they
got cold feet and decided to make the
trailer con exclusive which even though
it sounds like kind of a dick move
Marvel does that all the time they
always bring footage to Hall H at Comic
Con when they do go to Comic Con they
skip last year but they've been every
other year since then they always bring
a clip that's some unfinished version of
whatever upcoming movie they have so
last year it was Avengers infinity war
they had a rough cut of that big battle
on Titan with a nose but they don't
allow that
online even though those clips always
leak online surprisingly I haven't seen
any spider-man far from home CC XP
trailer leak I think they've just gotten
better and locking down people's cameras
and security at these big conventions
not that people don't try to record the
trailer but because there are two
trailers this Sony cut what might end up
happening is is they have an
international trailer in a regular
trailer with slightly different footage
they did the exact same thing for the
first big trailer for spider-man
homecoming a couple years ago where they
dropped two different trailers on the
same day but they have slightly
different footage if they do it again I
will totally post videos for both of
them the reason why some studios do that
and some do not is that some feel like
they don't need that international
trailer to give them a bump in that
place in the world but sometimes if
they're dropping an english-language
trailer in a foreign country they'll
change it so that it's a little more
action heavy and doesn't have as much
dialogue so that you don't have to speak
English to understand what's going on in
the trailer the funny interview about
spider-man far from home recently though
had to do with the fact that Marvel
turns out was actually a little upset
with Sony's plans for far from home
because as you would imagine they wanted
to keep spider-man's fate in Avengers
endgame a big secret like we all knew he
was coming back but Marvel actually
genuinely wanted that to be a surprise
when he does come back we learned about
that last year then they dropped the
infinity war trailer and we saw the
movie in April so people like wait a
minute
isn't he coming back for far from home
what what's going on why are you killing
him if he's coming right back the Russos
explain why they killed spider-man
offices because they wanted to get back
to the mains from the original Avengers
movies so it's mostly a lot of those new
characters that they kill off so you
have all the old original Avengers
bringing everyone back and then carrying
those new characters forward into Phase
four so we don't that they had any
special plans for terminating spider-man
on a permanent basis or anything like
that
he's a multi-billion dollar franchise
all by himself and Marvel still had the
solo movie left on their contract with
Sony to make so it's not like they're
gonna not make that movie but if he
didn't have a chance to see that see cxp
spider-man far from home trailer all it
is is it starts out with spider-man in
his stark tech suit speaking to a crowd
talking about something where Aunt May
and happy in the background have a
moment together then he gets ready to go
on his European
vacation says goodbye to Aunt May leaves
with his debate team friends without the
stark tech suit so he goes to Europe
without that suit which explains why
Nick Fury needs to give him this black
suit thanks to Cece XP we finally got a
really good up close look at it Sony
brought both versions of the new
costumes so there's a couple quick shots
of spider-man with his friends in Venice
walking around then Nick Fury creeps up
on them in their hotel room shoots Ned
in the neck with a dart so that he can
fall asleep and meet spider-man for the
first time and recruit him to work with
Mysterio to take down these
quote-unquote
elementals that apparently only Mysterio
knows how to deal with even though I do
think something fishy is going on with
that but in the trailer you see a bunch
of these different elementals one of
them even kind of looks like the Sandman
from spider-man 3 a little bit but
there's earth there's a water one
there's a wind one and then there's a
lava one Mysterio shows up in his tech
suit with comic-book fishbowl you'll be
happy to know that there is definitely a
fishbowl he starts fighting the monsters
in Venice and he uses what looks like
spells like Doctor Strange would with
the runes except his are green instead
of orange reddish like dr. Strange's so
it looks like he's weaving magic like
dr. strange would although like I said
Mysterio pulls lots of tricks you get a
couple shots of spider-man in the
stealth suit you get a quick shot of him
at the red and black suit with the wings
under his arms then the trailer ends
with him fighting one of the monsters in
Peter in his regular plain clothes with
no suit on the trailer footage is cut up
from all different parts of the film's
so it's not meant to be linear I think
London is one of the first places that
they go on their class trip
quote-unquote like they fly from New
York to London then they start going
around Europe but I do like the idea
that even though these elemental
creatures are a bit of a deep cut from
the Doctor Strange comics and Mysterio
is pulling some very classic comic books
spider-man Mysterio tricks they still
find a really subtle way to reference a
little bit of Sam Raimi Tobey Maguire
spider-man with some of these creature
designs but like I said I'm not
expecting a trailer Tuesday like
everyone thought was going to happen
they might wait till next week if I hear
any news about it or Tom Holland gets
all hopped up on codeine or whatever
drugs they gave him after they pulled
his wisdom teeth out and accidentally
quote-unquote spoils the trailer that I
will totally make a video
for it no worries so ever to just hope
that he gets super loopy this weekend
just accidentally tweets out a link to
the video even though it would be
hilarious if he did something like that
I don't think that Sony would go so far
because he really did get his wisdom
teeth out to use that as an excuse to
market their trail
I think they'll wait till he's recovered
a little bit but it is funny to watch
him do stuff like this quick reminder -
in related news there's a Hellboy
trailer dropping on Thursday I will
totally do a video for it no worries
congratulations David Vasquez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for that new Iron Man
Avengers endgame promo and click here
for all those new Game of Thrones season
8 promos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]